Greetings everybody, my name is Sam Dider and I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor with
Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial, we're going to be taking a look at Niagara fluids.
We're first going to start by taking a look at an overview of Niagara fluids, going over
the various fluids that we can make using the system.
We're next going to jump into Unreal and look at how we enable the Niagara fluids plugin.
Then we'll take a look at the various Niagara fluid content example maps, which show you
how you can utilize fluids in many different ways inside of the engine.
It's a great resource to come back to to see what you can do with the various fluid emitters
that Unreal Engine 5 provides.
Next we're going to take a look at creating 2D smoke, liquid and fire effects by actually
creating some smoke and 2D liquid effects.
We're then going to move on to creating 3D liquid smoke and fire effects.
Then finally we're going to finish up with some ways to optimize our smoke, liquid and
fluid effects so that they can run more performant and even be used on platforms that might not
necessarily support them.
With this introduction out of the way, let's go ahead and get started by taking a look
at our Niagara fluids overview.